this is a very personal thing you will
never get it by looking only at other
people but at the end of the day it's
doing a multi-dimensional full circle
audit of what fulfillment looks like for
you looking at your life and see what
needs to change
what's that belief nation it's having my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna look at the
seven ways to find fulfillment enjoy so
I think this is a topic that a lot of
people struggle with not just
entrepreneurs but humans people want to
be fulfilled it is it is a human need
and a lot of people are not living their
life in a way that is leading to
fulfillment and so this is a really
important video and I hope through these
seven ways it opens up a light to allow
you to make progress to finding a
fulfilling path for you so let's kick it
off with way number one self-awareness
this has to be the starting point a main
reason why so many people don't feel
fulfilled is they're comparing
themselves to other people
comparison is great my own success is
great as long as you're using it as the
kick forward not to kick down to say
that's something that's really cool that
they're doing and I want to learn from
that and apply to my life as opposed to
saying that person is really great and I
suck and I'm never gonna be great what
fulfillment looks like to you is unique
to you what happiness ultimately looks
like to you what success ultimately
looks like to you this is a very
personal thing you will never get it by
looking only at other people you might
love Steve Jobs you might think easier
he's a big visionary you might love
Kanye West's on the wall too you might
love me and my content but stepping into
anybody schedule will not be fulfillment
because you are living somebody else's
life and not your own and so it doesn't
matter what your parents think or your
friends think of the people around you
think what matters is you two have the
self-awareness if you grow what
fulfillment actually looks like for you
and so what I recommend doing is taking
afternoon off every quarter go to your
calendar every quarter find whether it's
a week their weekend one afternoon off
to
thinking about this it's kind of
important you might want to bookmark
sometime for like if you can't find one
afternoon every quarter to dedicate to
this then you don't deserve to have a
fulfilled life you're not putting in any
effort so half a day once a quarter in
that first hour you spend just
disconnecting from the stresses of the
world you go for a walk in the park you
sit in a coffee shop you'd go to the
library like whatever the thing is that
helps you relax unwind put some music on
whatever the thing is to forget about
the stresses of of home and and work and
colleagues and the business all of that
just that you can be in a relaxed state
then you sit down take out a notepad and
just write down what if fulfilled life
looks like to you you and you alone it
doesn't matter what anybody else wants
you to do wants you to think wants you
to act what does it look like for you
you got to get clarity over that and
every quarter you sit down and you
adjust is this still accurate is this
still how I want to live is this still
in alignment with where I'm going that
is one of the most important things that
you can do for yourself if you take that
time every quarter
[Music]
way number two is make it
multi-dimensional a lot of times when we
look at fulfillment we only look at one
thing we look at what its fulfillment
look like in business or what does the
film look like in my relationship but
what does filament look like being a
parent or being a son or daughter or
brother or sister it's all connected all
of it is connected together if you have
a really bad day at work or if even
worse if you hate your job there's no
way you're coming home as a happy person
and you're gonna be a great husband or
wife right or great mother or father
there's no way everything bleeds into
each other if you're having a stressful
relationship at home you're gonna bring
that stress to your work you're not
gonna be massively productive in your
business if your relationship was on the
rocks and is in chaos and so when you're
sitting down doing your exercise it's
gotta be your entire life everything
altogether it might be daunting it might
sound ambitious but that's what you need
to do if you want to actually feel
fulfilled
don't just default to one area of life
if I look at Steve Jobs I might want to
model some of the visionary NIST's right
how do I be visionary like Steve Jobs
how can I learn from that to help me get
better but I don't want to be a parent
like him I don't want to be a father
like him I'll pull that from from my
actual parents who are down there in the
middle right and so yes you can model
success and learn from other people but
at the end of the day it's doing a
multi-dimensional full circle audit or
what fulfillment looks like for you
looking at your life and seeing what
needs to change
[Music]
way number three is explore explore
explore if you don't know what you want
to do if you don't know if a feeling
quite looks like yet then you need to
taste it you need to try it you need to
say yes to things used to get out there
you won't be able to only come up with a
complete definition by you spending that
one afternoon once a quarter because
you're only in your head it's only where
you can think about where at the end of
the day this is an emotion fulfillment
is an emotion that we're seeking and
that's gonna come from the heart so big
decisions come from the heart so you
plan it out it's great like see you
still want to plan the plan is important
you plan it out once a quarter and then
you start testing you start seeing you
start trying and when you feel things
like doing this makes you feel fulfilled
doing this you thought would but didn't
great so you tried it let's move on you
continue to adjust that once a quarter
schedule because you're tasting you're
trying you're seeing what is actually
working for you weight number four is to
serve others ultimately I think humans
are designed to help others I think we
feel great about ourselves we feel great
about the work that we're doing when
it's helping others when it's in service
to other people and it doesn't have to
be some big mission even just helping
your neighbor you know move in or move
out or move that piano or helping a
friend through a tough time when you
know that what you're doing the time
that you're spending is having a
meaningful impact on at least one person
that makes you feel good and so it's
wrongly recommending your quarterly
audit to look at how much of the
activities that you have planned out are
in service in some way to other people
and the more that are aligned with
helping others the more you will
actually feel fulfilled
[Music]
way number five is have a greater
purpose if you look at the people who
are the most fulfilled quite often they
have a bigger purpose they have a bigger
vision they want to take that service
that they know they can help one or two
or three people close to them and they
want to make it bigger
now that might mean you know Elon Musk
trying to colonize Mars to have a
back-up plan for the planet but it could
just be serving your communities some
ways serving your school in some ways
serving the local clubs in some way it
doesn't have to be some great big bull
plane as entrepreneurs we're usually
pretty ambitious and we want to go off
and do that thing but don't feel bad if
you don't have massive ambitions just
the idea for you to feel fulfilled just
the idea that you are doing work that is
serving many people not just one or two
or three really helps fill that soul on
a regular basis way number six is change
your environment like many things
actually following through on taking
action is going to come down to the
environment that you're in and if you're
in a toxic environment with negative
people who complain and blame and just
stress out all day long that's gonna be
a really hard environment to be in to
feel fulfilled and so you may not get to
choose your parents you may not to get
to choose your brothers and sisters you
may not get to choose a school that
you're at but you can choose the
resources that you consume you can
choose the videos that you watch you can
choose the books that you read you can
choose the events that you go to and if
you can't just quite yet then you will
be able to soon and so make that choice
powerfully don't make that choice by
accident don't just fall into life
design your routine design your habits
is on your environment to serve you and
so I guarantee you if you are hanging
around people virtually by watching
their videos reading their books if
you're hanging around these people who
are fulfilled who are chasing their
mission who are serving other people who
have self-awareness I guarantee you that
will rub off on you that will reinforce
on a daily basis the importance if you
want to work out and you're hanging
around people who are working out all
the time that will make you want to work
out more and so that applies to
everything so the challenge is then to
design an environment where that is
constantly in your face where every day
you're starting your day by reading the
book
watching a video with somebody who is
fulfilled living out their purpose that
will inspire you to go out and maintain
yours and we number seven is to fix your
calendar all of this is great talk all
of these are great ideas nothing happens
until you actually take action you got
to do right that this is the 2% of
thinking and strategizing which is
really important but then you have to do
after you do your quarterly sit downs
and you do your audit and you're alone
in the woods and you're figuring out
what does the filament like for you then
you have to do it and you do it by
looking at your calendar if you have
your goals for here's what you want to
accomplish here's what fulfillment looks
like for you is how you're spending your
time how much of that actually maps to
where you are spending your time because
if you plan out here's what fulfillment
looks like to me and then you look at
your calendar and you're only doing 1%
of those things you're not gonna be
fulfilled right and listen that that
might be a road map like you may not be
able to do everything right now
that's great awareness that's great
understanding but you want to try to hit
as much as possible so if this quarter
you're hitting 20% of the things that
help you make you feel fulfilled that's
great even just knowing what those 20%
are is amazing progress and then as you
start building up the next quarter could
be 25 and then 30 and then 40 and then
45 and then 50 and gradually you're
building more and more and more to a
more fulfilled life and that may mean
you need to build a bigger business you
need to bring in more resources you need
to build a bit of team as long as
there's hope as long as you feel like
you're making progress that's the
difference if you have a definition for
what if a field life looks like for you
and even if you can't be achieving that
right now if you're making progress
towards it and there's hope that you can
actually accomplish it that's enough
that builds momentum to get you going
but if you look at your calendar and
there's optional things in there like
you might be you might be forced right
now to do some of the things those
optional things in there use that time
wisely use that time purposefully use
that time to help you build the life
that you want so those are my seven ways
and how to find fulfilment I would love
to know which one had the biggest impact
on you did I miss an 8 9 10 that you
want to add to the list please leave it
down the comments below thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever
you're one where it is much-loved I'll
see you soon if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like I
am Tulsa what a wail out of a handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 4 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access